it is plain to see that something has
gone very badly wrong
allow me to highlight the most recent
example
genuinely dangerous a deeply pernicious
destabilizing influence and someone who
mi5 is gonna have to watch like a hawk
does that sound like the kind of person
you want wandering the streets
no me neither alas that is exactly what
will be happening this week when the
hate preacher
anjem choudary the man to whom those
recent descriptions belong
will be released from prison after
serving just
half of his terrifyingly lower sentence
to remind you anjem is the man who led
the hate group
to which one of the men who savagely
murdered fusilier lee rigby
was linked so i'm going to keep this
really simple
by allowing these people to be released
and to remain in our country
our government and legal system has
failed us
and has unquestionably put us at risk
[Music]
i agree with you michelle whoa and i
have a lot of respect for max hill the
um
official reviewer of counterterrorism
laws who said that he is concerned that
sentences for people
convicted of terrorism offences are too
low i mean we have a policy where people
often do serve half their sentences and
i think that
if we have sentences that are too low
and then people are released halfway
through
that is a concern and there are other
things that worry me as well like the
fact that we have a record number of
people
convicted of terrorism in prisons that
are struggling with basic security
and are not able to counter the
radicalization that's going on in
prisons and there's evidence that
people convicted for low level offences
are being radicalized by very serious
extremists now prisons that to me
is unacceptable and by not investing in
having prisons that can manage the
population property we're costing
ourselves
far more down the line in our society
but i do just want to
raise an issue about someone like anjem
choudhary who i think
reminds us that freedom of speech is not
absolute
the things that he says cross the line
into inciting hate and i think that's
absolutely right that he's been
convicted
but i do remember michelle you sitting
around this table
in support of tommy robinson who's
another example to me of somebody who
claims freedom of speech to promote
views
that actually promote hate so i think we
have to be consistent if we want to
condemn someone like anjan chaudhry who
i think we absolutely rightly do
we need to apply the same approach to
people on the extreme right who promote
hate
and actually there's growing concern
about the far right as a terrorist
threat and an acknowledgement now
that we haven't taken that threat
seriously enough so i agree with you
about angel and childhood but i would
like you
to apply that same thinking across the
spectrum when there are threats of
terrorism and hate
right so no before i bring anyone else
in no i absolutely
will not apply my
thought process to the things that anjem
chowdhury says which i think are dis
they are so disgraceful and disgusting
this is a man who
hates our way of living i've agreed with
who
encourages um actively encourages people
to kill us to celebrate when they've
done so
and is a just a terrible human being
to relate that to the things that tommy
robinson says
of which many of those are very
unpalatable to various people
i don't remember maybe i've i haven't
studied the back works of tommy robinson
by any stretch
but i don't i can't recall him standing
on the streets telling people to go and
kill other people and to celebrate when
they do so if you can tell me when tommy
robinson has done that please that i
will apologize revolting against the
hand that's actually feeding him the
point about
someone like anjem chowdhury is that i
don't as far as i am aware no you can't
compare what he says to people like
tommy robinson somebody who necessarily
is going to carry out offenses himself
the problem with angen choudhury is that
he incites other people
to commit acts of hate it's very similar
to situation with
tom robinson who's being used by the
extreme far right who have openly nazi
views who've advocated
mass deportations the banning of the
mosques the banning of berkeley
and the passage of people from minority
groups
i don't think you can and gem chowdery
to tommy robinson but we'll part that
um presumably you like you believe you
like living in this country because
we have the rule of law you cannot have
a situation where
heinous though his crimes are and we all
agree with that you sort of say right
well
normally you can come out halfway
through your term unless you burn the
prison down
but because we particularly don't like
you you're going to have to do
all your term i'll take you back to your
intro when you said that
the problem lies with the quotes do you
use your words michelle
terrifyingly
the terrifyingly low sentence that
chowdy was initially given
that let's go back up the conveyor belt
let's as max hill the independent uh
reviewer
counter-terrorism legislation let's go
back up there let's make these longer
terms so that when chowdy is convicted
of something for the purpose of debate
he's given 15 years then he serves seven
away with children seriously the stuff
that he said isn't redeemable as far as
i'm concerned
he really did absolutely go up against
everything in this country so
what he's said and what he's done and
what he's great he didn't feel they
should have
like but they should have found the key
okay is your point but they should be
still for sentences and it should have
been an absolute fill
they didn't we have a system of laws by
which we all live and that's why we're
sounding so reasonable now
this is disturbing we're having a
conversation with the pledge
yeah welcome well they're just it's
disturbing this
place is disturbing using in a good way
this is certainly a bad way there are
two things happening here one is we
don't like this guy
so let's actually decide that the rule
of law doesn't apply to him
that's not that that's exactly what i'm
saying no that is exactly what you said
no i'm not
please allow me to clarify well let me
finish what i'm saying first of all
the rules that apply to everybody else
may not apply to this guy because you
don't like it
that's what i'm saying that's saudi
arabia
that's saudi arabia well it doesn't
matter what he's done the law
deals dealt with you asked me what i
would do no
no i'm just dealing with what you said
number one
the rule of law appears not to be good
enough for this
guy as far as you're concerned well
that is exactly what anjem troudery
wants to happen
he wants liberal democracies to
demonstrate
that they actually don't live by the
rules that they say they do
they want he wants us to show ourselves
as hypocrites
and that's exactly why you'll get it
you're going to get into the wrong place
what you two are saying you're basically
saying oh michelle don't like this guy
so she wants a special occasion no i and
by the way i don't like him you're right
by the way
but what i'm saying is he's had a fixed
term sentence
applied to him which by by definition
automatically enables him to be released
halfway through so my problem is i'm not
saying let's make a special exception to
a fixed term sentence just for this guy
i'm saying the guy should never have
received a fixed term sentence in the
first place
he should have had an ongoing and you
know you'll probably know more than me
about what the legal definition of this
is
but there are sentences that you can
apply to somebody that's not fixed term
that doesn't have an automatic right of
um release halfway through
the things of which he was convicted
about indefinite
indefinite sentences for public
protection yeah the point is if you want
to have that in terrorism offences which
i think is a discussion that can be had
then that would need to happen through a
process and we have parliament to pass
laws
that needs to happen that's why i raised
max hill has
raised concern that the current system
for sentences
we're now on to a different conversation
conversation
with what the prisons minister at the
same